je le disais j'ai réfléchi cats a été
neutralisée au mail terme entre
guillemets parce que c'est celui qui est
employée fréquemment dans les médias il
a été abattu par la police hier le
terroriste est ce que du coup on peut
être rassuré est ce que la vie peut
reprendre un cours normal
écoutez ce qu'en pense roland ries c'est
le maire de strasbourg pour lui oui on
peut enfin passer entre guillemets à
autre chose heureux de cela parce que je
pense que ça va faciliter le retour à
une vie que je qualifierais de normal
c'est-à-dire serez base des valeurs qui
sont les nôtres de notre histoire sur la
base aussi de nos habitudes de vie
tout cela peut non plus facilement se
réaliser alors je précise que roland
ries s'est exprimé hier soir après
l'annnonce de la mort des shérifs 6 4%
qui disait qu'il était heureux et pas
après l'annonce bien plus récente d'une
quatrième victime mathieu bock-côté
quand vous entendez le maire de
strasbourg 10 dire on peut revenir à une
ce cas je qualifierais d'une vie normale
ça vous paraît un bon diagnostic
parce que la peur du terrorisme fait
désormais partie de la vie normale c'est
à dire l'inquiétude devant le terrorisme
islamiste et et intérioriser peu à peu
par nos sociétés nous savons que la
menace est partout présente en ce sens
nous savons par ailleurs que tous
portent une cible offrant qu'ils soient
civils ou militaires
homme ou femme enfant ou parent donc
l'eau oui dans les circonstances
l'assassin le terroriste a été abattu
très bien il n'en demeure pas moins que
nous savons aujourd'hui que nous la
démocratie pacifiée la démocratie des
livres et de la peur de la mort violente
ce n'est plus notre époque
la peur de la mort violente ressurgi
dans la cité et nous cherchons à nous
habituer à cette réalité ancienne mes
nouvelles
on va se calmer on peut voir ce dossier
deux aspects ou bien le dire la police a
été efficace évidemment c'est un c'est
un drame mais
il ya eu entre guillemets le traitement
qui était possible ou alors dire c'est
terrible parce que n'importe qui un
alsacien né en alsace comme disait le
député en marche de cette
circonscription peut prendre les armes
et est tiré dans la foule
oui mais on sait pas n'importe qui quand
même ce cette personne là c'est assez
normal de vouloir reprendre une vie
normale après un traumatisme comme celui
là donc roland ries ça a ses raisons
d'autant plus que pour strasbourg et
c'est pas scandaleux de le dire la
période de noël est une période très
importante avec le marché de noël il ya
des milliers et des milliers de
touristes qui viennent donc ils ont sait
que pendant deux trois jours tout ça a
été un peu gelé donc il faut retrouver
une vie normale
là où on peut être un peu plus inquiet
c'est sur la façon dont chez 4 est passé
à l'acte
parce qu'au fond on connaît pas encore
exactement évidemment ce serait une
motivation on laisse au rap sans doute
peut-être jamais mais le fait est qu'ils
essaient à la suite d'une perquisition
dans laquelle comme laquelle il était
visé pour des histoires de banditisme
visiblement qu'il prit la fuite ils
étaient prévenus on sera là aussi plus
tard et en tout cas qu'il est qu il est
passé à l'acte de cette manière
terroriste et donc ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que chez les
policiers aujourd'hui il ya une
réflexion et chez les politiques pour
toutes ces personnes nahla qui sont
fichés est-ce qu'ils sont radicalisées
dont on se dit peut-être qu'ils peuvent
passer à l'acte est-ce que alors qu'on
sait que ce sont des voyous deux fichés
au grand banditisme aussi où en est issu
est ce qu'il faut faire des
perquisitions et ce qu'il faut pas
éviter de donner un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière et puis le problème
maintenant c'est que d'aider des gens
avec ce profil là c'est à dire à la fois
délinquants et et islamistes radicaliser
y en a des centaines peut être des
milliers en flèche pour poursuivre la
réflexion mon voisin moi je dirais que
ce qui est embêtant dans cette histoire
là et c'est pour ça qu'on est pas tout à
fait tranquille c'est que un cas comme
ça c'était à caen
un fichier avec une personne à une
personne fichée s dont on sait qu'elle
est en plein dans la délocalisation
qu'il ya des délinquants de droit commun
et qu'on attrape pas et qui commet
ensuite des crimes
c'est déjà arrivé une fois je me
souviens il s'est échappé lyon était à
marseille et donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas vraiment de retour d'expérience dans
les organisations et dans l'organisation
de la sécurité
c'est ça qu'il ya des choses qui sont un
peu inquiétantes c'est peut-être un peu
tôt faire le bilan mais il va falloir le
faire parce qu'il ya cette chose là qui
est inquiétant l'autre chose c'est que
le marché de noël normalement c'est le
point névralgique du terrorisme fans
l'antitrust depuis des années et des
années ça fait des années qu'on sait que
le marché de noël et menacé par des
attentats terroristes
et pourtant un terroriste a réussi voilà
et ça c'est un fait majeur moi je
n'entends pas beaucoup j'entends là il
faudra que monsieur castaner parce que
c'est lui le ministre en charge il
faudra que les autorités de l'état fasse
le retour d'expérience on manque
beaucoup de recteur autour d'expériences
ça c'est un défaut français c'est qu'on
veut pas regarder je signale que par
ailleurs un des ministres maintenant
c'est l'ancien directeur la dgsi donc il
faudrait que le ministre fasse de
retours d'expériences monsieur d'une
espèce le retour de monsieur minasse
ministre doit faire le retour
d'expérience de monsieur younès
directeur général de la de directeur
général de sécurité intérieure tessa son
titre voilà il ya beaucoup de choses un
peu compliquées il faudrait peut-être
que du côté des français on se on se
dessine un peu et on décide quand on
d'ailleurs effectivement aller regarder
même là où ça fait un petit peu mal
une dernière chose oui je suis d'accord
nous nous savons maintenant que nous
sommes mortels voilà mais nous devons
défendre la démocratie pour qui pour
nous c'est un peu grandiloquent mais qui
devrait être immortel et une des
difficultés qu'on a c'est de vivre
normalement notre démocratie
voilà est ce qu'il faut être capable de
faire c'est dire oui nous nous allons
nous remettre à vivre normalement notre
démocratie ce qui est d'ailleurs on
verra le débat plus tard mais je pense
qu'on aura du mal à lui à tunis voudrais
vous soumettre cette réflexion de nicole
qui nous dit oui la traque a été
efficace celle contre le shérif chez cat
mais à chaque fois c'est pareil et on
sait que ça recommencera même si on ne
sait pas ni où ni quand exactement
et ça illustre pour moi la difficulté à
dire qu'on vit on reprend une vie
normale
le jour d'après moi je m'inscris en faux
contre ce vocabulaire édulcoré où on
doit revivre normalement et où on
neutralise on ajuste tuez le
l'attaquante une féminisation des choses
est juste le lendemain l'attentât ont
dit on reprend une vie normale mais
c'est impossible on a peur on a tous
peur quand on a des enfants on est
tétanisé d'angoise le real a lieu et un
moment c'est aussi une forme de déni de
réalité de dire ben on va faire comme si
de rien était vive normalement c'est
finalement faire comme si de rien
n'était donc moi je comprends très bien
la flexion de manable le réel changement
réalité change il faut la prendre en
compte et la peur c'est depuis depuis
l'antiquité les philosophes ont critiqué
ce sentiment en disant c'est la passion
la plus puérils la plus influente il a
peur alter des représentations donc il
ne faut pas avoir peur simplement
d'autres philosophes ont si audi que la
peur était un principe heuristique et
c'est très bien d'avoir peur parce que
tu as quoi un principe de connaissances
c'est comme ça qu'elle s'est fondée le
principe de précaution par hans jonas
qui a dit la peur est un principe qui
permet de bornes et devenir cadres et
des pratiques humaines et la peur est un
bon levier pour repenser nos façons de
faire nos façons d'agir donc je trouve
que là il faut utiliser la peur comme
levier ne pas en faire une passion a
éradiqué mais au contraire en faire un
principe d'action et de changer la
réalité les dispositifs et la traque a
évidemment été efficace mais enfin quand
on en a vu le nombre de peu de 700
policiers enfin forces de l'ordre sur un
individu s'est quand même je n'enlève
rien au mérite des policiers mais enfin
c'est quand même normal et qu'elle est
qu'il l'ait attrapé et voici ce qu'ils
ont attrapé les brigades de la police de
sécurité du quotidien c'est à dire que
c'est pas est ce qui n'enlève rien comme
vous dites alors éric mais c'est pas
tous les gens du raid tous les policiers
du raid
mathieu bock-côté dans cette volonté
réaffirmée de reprendre une vie normale
c'est un petit peu comme après le
bataclan on disait on va on va se
remettre à la terrasse des cafés
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de dire
préfère penser à la suite que de penser
aux causes c'est à dire le terrorisme
islamiste
enfin il est normal de vouloir les
mettre de côté le traumatisme est en
réflexion mais tout à fait naturel il
n'en demeure pas moins que pour
l'horizon historique qu'ils n'ont pour
l'époque qui est la nôtre de terrorisme
islamiste ne peut pas être traitée sous
le signe du fait divers
d'ailleurs voilà je crois que le commun
des mortels l'a compris ça
fondamentalement même si un certain
discours médiatique cherche à
neutraliser les événements donc on
cherche toujours ramener ça là bas
ça a étouffé la signification des
événements par les deux loups solitaires
qu'on n'ose plus faire le nom on parle
du loup solitaire mais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on dit on cherche mon
pantalon on attend pendant longtemps le
nom quelques fois et on cherche à nous
dire tout de suite que c'est peut-être
autre chose c'est peut-être un crime
ce titre fait divers terrible mais au
fait divers néanmoins or ou devant des
événements comme ceux là je crois qu'il
est important aujourd'hui de rappeler la
signification politique de tels gestes
c'est à dire c'est eux et de voir qu'un
modèle d'actions propres djihadisme qui
est apparu dans nos sociétés
ça veut dire qu'on vire ses affluents
sont convertis radicaliser islamisés
fait le projet mais si le terme que vous
voulez peut assez rapidement pour peu
qu'ils mettent la main sur une arme
décidé de s'improviser soldat du djihad
et semer la terreur dans nos sociétés
c'est un modèle d'action qui se
reproduit au fil du temps sa peine avec
un couteau comme 7 avec un fusil
mitrailleur dans les circonstances
voilà pourquoi on doit on ne doit pas
neutraliser la signification politique
de ce qui vient de se passer quand même
jusqu'en le secrétaire d'état à
l'intérieur parle d'un terroriste
radicalisé mais sans faire mention de sa
religion
vous pensez que c'est une parce que j'ai
dû spes de gènes de la pole de la classe
politique par rapport à par rapport à
l'islamisme radical et violent il y en a
certains qui ont une gêne ça c'est
évident on le voit bien qu'ils n'osent
pas dire les mots après il ya aussi une
habitude c'est à dire que quand on parle
de deux terroristes de personnes
radicaliser on sait et les français
savent à qui ça ferait ça a fait
référence elle vit 2015
au fond c'est ça va mieux en le disant
je suis d'accord avec vous et au fond
d'ailleurs ça serait beaucoup plus
simple qu'il le dise on éviterait comme
ça de franc-parler qu'on va être très
d'accord la table mais il faut dire les
choses il faut montrer aux noms plus de
photos pas de photos pas les noms
souvent les noms des noms des acteurs
des crimes sont gommées où sont réduits
à des as les initiales on ne veut pas
voir et au contraire si on veut faire la
politique faut nommer celle inverse et à
faut dire ce sont des terroristes
islamistes
voilà c'est pas mal le terme
radicalisation des insurgés
ça ça ramène à la racine donc c'est un
petit peu compliqué et donc je pense que
pour les images et les noms comme moi
n'ont pas du tout mais au tout début les
deux pour les deux premiers jours mon
avis il ne peut même pas parler d'acte
terroriste et lâche rien à la racine du
mot terroriste un acte qui crée la
terreur qui sèment la terreur quand même
un acte terroriste
mais et c'est ça qui rend et je pense
qu'on va en parler après aussi les
politiques inaudibles parce qu'au pays
de la langue de bois à un moment ne pas
dire les véritables chose avoir peur des
mots comme si le mot chien mort des ça
devient très très néfaste pour les pois
les orateurs et pour les hommes
politiques
peut-être je mettrais un bémol c'est que
là dessus le secrétaire d'état ne naisse
et peut-être encore policiers et pas
encore politique au sens où le policier
il attend d'avoir des confirmations
avandia rivaux on n'utilisait pas le
terme actions terroristes parce que pour
eux c'était quelqu'un qui était fiché au
banditisme radicalisé mais il n'avait
pas d'éléments comme quoi il était et
horizons qu'ils attendaient le nom
pareil parfois ils attendent quelques
heures avant de voir dell par
l'environnement alors qu'un politique et
là je suis d'accord avec vous son rôle
c'est plutôt de nommer les choses donc
c'est là où peut-être c'est plus normal
j'aurais juste un exemple l'utilisation
du mot terrorisme dans une terreur et ça
me fera pas encore non le terrorisme
n'est qu'un instrument parmi d'autres
en la matière le terrorisme islamiste il
faut le nommer si on ne nomme pas c'est
comme c'est une terreur planante
indiscernables insaisissable qui
traînait dans nos sociétés c'est pas
exactement ça donc voilà pourquoi je
crois qu'avant le moment les choses et
on restaure alors la valeur la parole
publique donnée juste un exemple sur les
depuis le quelques temps quelques mois
après le
les attentats de novembre contre le
bataclan et les autres les autres lieux
de paris on a posé des plaques sur les
biens de paris en souvenir pour en
commémoration des événements on ne sait
pas on sait qu'il ya des victimes
on sait qu'il ya eu un attentat on ne
parle même pas de terrorisme on sait
même pas on ne sait pas qui est
responsable de la mort des gens alors
que on met les noms alors alors que le
nom des victimes sont bien sûr les
plaques est donc un enfant de 15 ans qui
arriverait maintenant ou de 10 ans qui a
maintenant signé mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ici
voilà c'est on ne nomme pas voilà c'est
comme ça voilà on peut penser à cette
fois fallu mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter du malheur au monde une réaction
de monsieur babineau qui nous dit on dit
que ça c'est un terroriste islamiste
radicalisé mais on n'a aucun élément
concret pour le rattacher à une
organisation terroriste
alors c'est vrai parce que cette
initiative qu'il a pris lui-même même si
l'état islam et comme d'habitude a
revendiqué l'attentât après anti mac do
dis bravo à la police
je suis admiratif et brunes et elodie le
terrorisme à un but politique on n'est
pas certain que le geste était politique
donc c'est une volonté de neutraliser
ces les réflexes de sauvegarde de peur
dans les capacités de nos mails la
menace devant soi et je vois aussi
l'effet du politiquement correct cette
machine neutraliser le sens cette
machine à décomposer le sens qui écrase
le discours médiatique qui fais en sorte
qu'après le bataclan il y avait quelques
pointes de mémoire y avait la formule
des français d'origine belge et belges
d'origine française est de s'en prendre
aux aviez français en terrasse bon une
belge d'origine française des français
d'origine belge
quand on parle mais si tout le monde
comprend qu'on masquer la réalité et le
langage sert plaît à dire les choses
mais allez vous allez merci beaucoup ont
passé un an